talks continued this weekend is
congressional Democrats and the White
House try to strike a deal to provide
more money for a program than to help
small businesses shut down by the
coronavirus earlier I talked with the
Speaker of the House Nancy Pelosi about
that and more
speaker Pelosi good to talk to you again
the 350 billion dollar fund to provide
loans to small businesses has run out
President Trump says you and other
Democrats are blocking a deal to provide
another 250 billion here he is on that
Nancy Pelosi she's away on vacation or
something and she should come back she
should come back and get this done I
don't know why she's not coming back
the fact is she's not doing her job the
president says he now supports your call
for more money for hospitals but you're
also calling for more money for first
responders for food assistance for
states and local governments how long
are you prepared to hold out speaker
well I think they're on a very good path
first of all I support the cares Act we
were very pleased to be able to turn it
from a corporate trickle-down bill to a
workers first bubble up and support the
PPP the Paycheck protection program in
there and so as they have committed the
money that is there we want to add more
money there it is very urgent though
that we support our our police and fire
our health care workers our nurses our
teachers and that's what the state and
local government is about is meeting the
needs of the coronavirus and everything
that we're doing is about the
coronavirus understand that we're not
going a field and any other thing and
also to make sure that everyone has
access to the the program I'm very
pleased at the progress that is being
made we've worked in a very bipartisan
way all along would continue to do so we
all pay tribute to our small businesses
which are the optimism the
entrepreneurial spirit of America
and we don't want there be any doubt
that if there are participating in the
program that they will be funded and if
they meet the standards of the program
that they loans will be forgiven so is
there gonna be a deal and if so how soon
you know there are a lot of small
businesses that are running out of money
and are hanging on by their fingernails
yes and and we want all of them to get
what they're entitled to under the under
the law and even more than were that
some of these small businesses have
other requests in terms of the
additional loan program is tradition to
that grant program and that's part of
our request as well the money has not
all been distributed although it has all
been committed and that's that means
there's no more money they will have
more money as soon as we come to
agreement which will be soon and I think
people will be very pleased because
these small businesses must thrive in a
community where there again health is
essential to them opening up and they
have to open up in order to thrive it's
one thing to save them the day it's
another thing to have customers at the
end of the day the president announced a
plan this week to reopen the country and
you immediately criticized it I want to
put up what you said the White House is
vague an inconsistent document does
nothing to make up for the president's
failure to listen to the scientists and
produce and distribute distribute
national rapid testing but dr. Anthony
Fauci endorsed the plan take a look if
these things are done correctly what I
believe they can we will have and there
will be enough tests to allow us to take
this country safely through phase one
don't you believe doctor foul shape yo
he said if this were to drown properly
well it hasn't been done on March fourth
we passed our first bill bipartisan
testing testing testing it's over six
weeks since and
hasn't been done so he's saying if it is
done properly we're already very late on
that but he's right it has to be testing
it has to be tracing contact tracing it
has to be treatment and it has to be
quarantined it's part of something
bigger as well to be done properly but
we're way late on it and that is the
failure the president gets an F a
failure on the testing but the doctor
faustus right if it is done properly it
hasn't been and that I think really puts
it in the if it's done
is it admission that it hasn't been done
you as you are right now have been very
critical of President Trump especially
for what you say is the time that he
lost initially in January and February
in responding to the virus but I want to
point out that on February 24th you went
on a walking tour of Chinatown to try to
promote tourism there and here's some of
what you had to say that's what we're
trying to do today is to say everything
is fine here come because the
precautions have been taken we think
it's very safe to be in Chinatown and
hope that others will come if the
president underplayed the threat in the
early days Speaker Pelosi didn't you as
well know what we're trying to do is to
end the discrimination the stigma that
was going out against the asian-american
community and in fact if you will look
the record will show that our Chinatown
has been a model of containing and
presenting the virus so I'm confidence
in our folks there thought it was
necessary to offset some of the things
that the president and others were
saying about asian-americans and making
them a target a target of violence
across the country and said don't you
think don't you think that you when
you're out walking without any mass I
understand this is February not April
when this happened and saying that
there's no threat it's perfectly safe
there weren't you also adding to this
perception that there wasn't such a
threat generally
now I was saying that you should not
discriminate against discriminate
against Chinese Americans as some in our
administration were doing by the way
they were labeling the flu and that no
indeed and again I think you if you
check the record and its current you
will see that arch that Chinatown has
been a model and all of this and that's
what we're saying look to them for the
answers don't look to them to place
blame as you know protests against the
stay at home orders are growing across
the country people are taking to the
streets pushing back against some of the
more stringent restrictions in some
states can you understand why they're
doing that
no not really because what we have to do
is is is shelter in place that is really
the answer
testing tracing treatment shelter in
place and I do think that it's
unfortunate but you know people will do
what they do
but the fact is we're all impatient we
will all want out but what they're doing
is really unfortunate because what is
great though is the America are the
American people the American people know
that the good health of themselves and
their families and their loved ones is
what is important and that's why you
have seen such a overwhelming commitment
to shelter in place and distancing
people distancing because really it is
the key to how we will open up our
economy the health issue is the key to
opening up the economy
unfortunately this what you see there is
you know good and I'm respectful
whatever people think that they should
say but the fact is this has to be
science-based
evidence-based data based and the
evidence and the science and the day
says shelter-in-place trait testing
contact tracing treatment quarantine is
the answer to opening up our economy
sooner I think there's a way I bet by
the way if I just may add I do think
focusing on that is a major distraction
from testing testing testing and so it
does it serve as a distraction yes but
that's not what this is about we're
supposed to be focusing on getting over
this so that we can open up our economy
the sooner the better and I'm proud of
got a comparable because by and large
they have embraced that a couple of
questions I want to get in just this
week you called President Trump a weak
person a poor leader now I understand
that he goes after you so this is fully
a two-way street
but do you think those kinds of partisan
attacks by in this case you are
constructive in the middle of a national
crisis well I'll tell you why I came to
that I was very prayerful on Easter it
was one of the first days I didn't have
to be working every minute and I could
reflect and be prayerful and what I
decide it was that the president's made
many mistakes okay let's have an
after-action review of that but if he
continued to put forth proposals that
were not science-based
continuing his you know Ferdie say it's
a hoax it's magically going to go away
okay put that aside but to proceed with
policies which were not science-based
which are not evidence-based and to
blame others name anybody blame the
governor's by me blaming the World
Health Organization leaders leaders take
responsibility so I said he's a weak
leader he doesn't take responsibility
he places blames blame on others and
that might have been okay for before but
we cannot continue down a path that is
again I'll come back to science science
science evidence day
on how we could go forward finally and
I've got about a minute left here
speaker Pelosi when this crisis started
you opposed the idea of Congress voting
remotely something it has never done
before but in the last week you have
said that you could support remote
voting under certain circumstances what
would you accept in that regard and why
the change of mind what was a change of
mind it was I asked their chairs of
jurisdiction chairman Jim McGovern the
Rules Committee chairwoman Zoe Lofgren
of the House Administration Committee to
say what are the options we can give
members this was weeks ago what are the
options that we can give members
constitutionally security-wise and
technologically oh they came back this
week with saying proxy voting is
probably something that passes muster on
those scores in terms of just for this
purpose not for life in general but for
this purpose and so that is I'm taking
their recommendation it wasn't a change
much my attitude was always if it's
possible let's see what the options are
this is what they have come back and
said is possible and we'll see if it has
to be bipartisan we'll see how our
colleagues on the other side of the
aisle I think there's some openness to
it you'd have to ask them but we would
want to do it and a Congress a
house-wide not just a determination of
the Democrats that that's the way we
want to go forward we want to do it in a
bipartisan way as we have done all of
this three bills in March all partisan
bipartisan not partisan at all and as
this interim package will be bipartisan
and we want to keep the faith on both
sides and with the public that this is
this is how we have to compromise we
want to make improvements but we have to
compromise to get the job done and I
might say I've worked with the
Republicans to pass a the keep
government open December to pass the
us-mexico Canada trade agreement we will
get ready for where we do work together
and I
point that out Speaker Pelosi again well
credit where credit predators do
criticism where criticism is due thank
you so much for coming and talking with
us please stay safe and please come back
and talk with us thank you and credit to
the American people for their patriotism
and their concern for their families
thank you